swing to dinner with your eighth person
swing table after you break out your
vintage baseball glove leather wallet
because it's episode 38 of loop start
your day using some perfectly shaved
soap courtesy of the soap Shamer
and guys look your best thanks to the
ABCs of men's fashion book maybe you
could add this portable pocket hoody
that attaches to any shirt to complete
your fresh look but if a hoodie isn't
enough to protect you from the elements
you could wear a lion ski mask which
will winterize your face while you ride
on this gas-powered snowboard it holds
up to 250 pounds and tops out at 18
miles per hour for something a little
less adventurous and a lot more little
fly the world's smallest quadcopter the
proto X is less than two by two inches
and weighs four tenths of an ounce
you could always blow up your arm with
this inflatable mini gun arm after that
you want to take a few laps while you
nap in your pool bed and gaze at your
glorious candle ear made up of 15,000
hand strong acrylic gummy bears or look
at your spark beats phone case that
lights up using the flash from your
phone's camera so you have enough light
to read k is for knife ball an alphabet
of terrible advice book including D is
for drifter G is for Grandma and a is
for Apple e one every day and wash it
down with your mom's Cabernet break the
rules and cheat with this apron cooking
guide that helps with cooking times how
to properly cook steaks and even
includes a spaghetti measuring guide
luckily you'll have a leaning tower of
pasta to keep that in and a Squirrel Nut
grinder that is a great little rodent
equally great is this condiment gun that
you might want to use to add some flavor
to your bizarre food.com a cool website
where you can buy all kinds of weird
foods from giant bug chili dipping paste
to chinese yellow scorpion candy
lollipops which you wash down with some
giant centipede whiskey that you carry
in this shot flask that has a shot glass
built
and to add some fizz to that whiskey get
a portable water carbonator that turns
still water into a bubbling delight in
less than three minutes but if that's
too much work just steal someone else's
drink with way a toy that transfers
liquids using the physics of a siphon if
your drinks too warm use the spin chill
to cool it down simply attach it to the
top of your container place it in ice
and spin check your mail when you see
this webmail notifier light up and
hopefully receive a nicer message then
you'll find in these misfortune cookies
don't listen to the cookies listen like
an audio file using meze headphones
they're handcrafted out of Ebony wood to
reproduce a warm natural sound whether
with the earbuds or these headphones
featuring a fancy ergonomic headband
really cute robot cleaner from Japan for
something cute and squishy for your
sweetheart gets squishables the adorable
squishable creatures feature custom
designs you can vote on to produce the
next squishy hedgehog or comfort food
toast then get comfy with this blanket
featuring built-in speakers to listen to
love songs as you cuddle up in your
tranquility pod the memory foam waterbed
has 50 LEDs that synchronize with your
heartbeat and it only costs $30,000 if
that's too extravagant keep warm with
these love gloves because you're
probably smitten finally make sure to
save up for a full-scale Space Shuttle
Orbiter replica that costs three and a
half million dollars and as always
thanks for watching
you